if you follow [ __ ] maybe SPN as an
amateur fighting ESPN I know right now
you gotta you gotta make up for that
with you everybody's looking for the
head kick the next one can't be
ground-and-pound at such a thing now
yeah I just get married to it thing
really early on right becomes a real
problem because real problem like you're
known as like if gauge he just decides
tomorrow to fight like tyron woodley
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's no crazy like what if gauge you
got a title shot against Tyron Woodley
and they both like mirrored each other
have you seen how hard your blade colby
commenting is getting going in the paint
announcer Graham Woodley oh my god I've
seen his recent one with the sandals he
did a Black Friday sale 50 sandals
mocking Woodley what did you know you
gotta see it how he's mocking Woodley
with sandals you'll see it like they're
not real sandals he's just like gaming
sure your sandals this Friday and it's
these sandals of Woodley saying one
thing why he'll fight Nate Diaz but
saying another thing wife won't fight
Colby there it is no Ariel GSP is
ducking me
he just wants money fights Ariel I'm not
ducking Colby or anyone at 170 I want to
fight Nate because it's a money fight
that seems like he's saying the same
thing yes he just keeps money fight I
want to fight Nate because it's a money
fight yeah I get it what do you do with
Woodley good question you offer him a
big fight I'm almost positive make sure
I'm right on this before I get destroyed
on the underground but I'm Dan goes we
never offered Woodley the Dia's fight
browser he's just trying to get it
pretty sure look the real Diaz fight as
the other Diaz that's the ridge is
suspended though let him pay that
[ __ ] money back
Tyron Woodley responds to claim Nate
Diaz fight was never offered delusional
Dana constant
we demotes me as a fighter whoa in
regards to what though Jimmy because is
the claim that Nate Diaz fight was never
offered to him delusional didn't Dana
yeah but did Dana say it constantly
demotes me as a fighter when the job is
when the job is to promote his fighters
especially champions Woodley said why
would I get in camp
why would Nate give a fifteen million
dollar purse request if there was no
fight it's obvious they haven't found
their blockbuster headliner yet this was
a reality and they know it the inability
to come to financial terms with Nate
killed it
oh there's but there's Dana going one of
our attorneys here started playing
matchmaker which is weird he said he has
a good rapport with the Diaz brothers
and he basically said to Nate what if
you could fight Woodley me and Sean show
we were like how does he deserve to
fight Woodley there's no effing list of
guys that are waiting to fight time
Woodley and there is a [ __ ] oh there is
there's a [ __ ] what he just guys
there you go yeah okay so the attorney
went out of his way the attorney the
attorney [ __ ] up who's this attorney
kind of slap dick attorney tries playing
these games that's what I would do fake
attorney quitter Twitter accounts no
would you be interested in that nice
grin I know you say a [ __ ] with Howard
are you get back dude didn't ask it on
the podcast [ __ ] yes dude to me his
career is a sad story it is the guy that
never was yeah well they didn't for
whatever reason they couldn't work it
out with him you know they had their
disagreement and also his fighting style
but for him never to compete there my
name is Gorton man if you're a fan of
fighting that style is important because
Ben Askren shuts [ __ ] down and
he shuts good guys like Lima and Baltar
man we've shut Lima down like korish
Cove shut him the [ __ ] shot him down
those are world class it's such a bummer
he never got in the UFC you know what I
got to be honest I think if that same
GSP showed up that fought Bisbing shows
up to fight Askren ask him beats him oh
I know crazy right to me ask him it's a
sad story it's a sad story I agree
he's my if I had one wish to get a guy
in the UFC that's never been in the US
he'd be the guy me too like his fate or
it's like you already get in the seam in
Bellator you don't just ko them you know
I get it but not at this stage at this
stage I would say without doubt it was
Askren I would use my golden ticket if I
had one with Dana to get askearn in yeah
I would too
but you know he called Dana like a fat
bald steroid monkey what does that mean
how many things has Dana said about guys
know you know like this is a style thing
to the word that is styles boring I
understand that they are in the business
of fighting but I mean I kind of am but
I'm kind of not I'm in the business of
I'm a fan of fighting and I'm not just a
fan of fighting like I like to watch
fights I want to see what the [ __ ]
really works the best and when a guy can
do what Ben Askren has been able to do
time and time again in his career two
world-class fighters take them down
smother them beat the [ __ ] out of them
that's entertaining it's not just
entertaining it's important for the for
the art form I agree to adapt to that
style that I'm gonna know that a guy can
do that to a guy like Lima well I got
like chorus correct but also been asking
Kentucky speaks well yes he can hype the
fight about social meaning he speaks
very well Olympian yeah he's also an
Olympian and how about this
Floyd Mayweather does not win fights
because this is exciting no Connor fight
yeah I see him lose cuz he's a good
trash talker we should start our own
promotion we really should I wish you
would go in a football field
I don't do football field freak party
fighting Productions is the matchmaker
first you have to listen to a 45 minute
seminar on this latter latest false
flags